you can't be the guy out there
constantly looking for your shots you've
got to pick up the scraps and do that
well and that's exactly what he does and
he finds booker here for the opening
bucket for
the phoenix suns
murray has been outstanding particularly
since coming back from health and safety
protocol as brooker
drains a little fade away over derrick
white
[Applause]
fun in the gym and booker
is red hot
as
[Music]
[Applause]
and charges drawn in fact the spurs as a
team are fourth in the league taking
charges
booker
wow
is one of three that is in the top five
all time of assist and steals
stockton and kid being the others oh
there's booker again getting loose
knocked away
landau couldn't come up with it and
underneath booker
over lonnie walker
spurs are 4 14 from three as all the
sons right now
booker stops this time on a dime and
gets the jumper over
yeah and again jacob is caught guarding
devin booker
that's more games that i played in all
together my entire career is incredible
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
open on the offensive class
[Applause]
booker with a three ball
here's booker
[Music]
[Applause]
and one for devin booker
30-point game
devin booker could already score the
ball without chris paul in the lineup
looks like he kind of
coming in at 39
he's slowly moving it forward like he
did last year later in the season
[Applause]
[Music]
he's going to be there
11 points eight rebounds for beyond the
spurs
i believe that's the third straight
turnover yeah and booker makes him pay
with an end scene from jacques landau
where he should have shot that ball and
he knows it now
but there you see
ben basel reaching across with his right
hand across the body of devin book and
biambo is everywhere
i think he's got a twin on the floor
with him tonight yeah exactly and booker
makes him pay booker tonight
six
assists four rebounds
and 44 points now
7-12 shooting murray stripped to the
basketball
paul ahead to booker for two
how about that pass there bill
turn it on
[Music]
to win the ball game they're winning by
20 points or 19 points
per game on the road to the last five
that's really impressive
makes it 119 104 with 249 to go the
zones have pretty well locked this one
up as booker has 48
and it's a matter of bonnie williams
wants him to
stay on and get half a hundred
[Music]
i don't know i think monty sees